You know, there are very few things that
set us apart
from the rest of life on Earth.
At the heart of them, I believe, is our
inexhaustible power of imagination.
Imagination is the ability to bring
into mind, things that aren’t present.
With imagination, we can
anticipate the future.
We can revisit the past.
You can step outside the present moment
and try and see things
as other people see them.
It’s through creativity that we develop
our architecture,
our scientific proofs,
and our works of art.
We don’t just
live in the world as we find it,
we create civilizations, theories,
technologies,
and we reach beyond the planet.
In honor of the life and work
of Sir Ken Robinson,
TED-Ed invites you to reimagine
the aspects of life we take for granted
by finishing the sentence:
imagine if ...
Visit ed.ted.com/ImagineIf
to learn more.